[Applaus]
[Musik]
in der vergangenen Woche erreichten uns
Nachrichten wie diese Kanzleramt soll
bereits im März Pipeline Lex befürchtet
haben rechnete die Bundesregierung mit
Sabotage Angriffen auf von Nord Stream
Hofreiter rechnet mit Scholz China
erinnert mich an Nord Stream wir haben
in den letzten Jahren eine Politik
betrieben die uns die Zumutungen der
Welt vom Hals gehalten hat dazu gehört
auch die kurzsichtige Russlandpolitik
darin war ja auch Angela Merkel eine
Spezialistin auch beim Hamburger
hafenstil mit China Scheren Scholz und
die SPD aus es ist keine gute Idee einem
autoritären Regime auch nur
24,9% von kritischer Infrastruktur zu
geben die Argumentation es ist eine rein
wirtschaftliches Projekt erinnert mich
an etwas an Nord Stream 2 auch hier gilt
wir sollten uns nicht erpressen lassen
auch nicht von China das ist ein Staat
der Unterschied inzwischen zur Diktatur
geworden ist die Abhängigkeit von
Deutschland von Diktaturen ist plötzlich
ein großes Thema geworden ein
überlebenswichtiges Thema bei den alle
mitreden wollen aber wie genau hängt
eigentlich alles zusammen wer wusste
wann was was hat der Teilverkauf des
Hamburger Hafens mit nostring 2 zu tun
hat Hofreiter recht wer ist eigentlich
Schuld an der ganzen Misere und wohin
steuern Deutschland und Europa in diese
sich rapide geänderten Welt wir wollen
heute in diesem rundumschlagvideo all
diese brennenden Fragen beantworten lass
uns aber bitte vorher einen kurzen
Werbehinweis unseres tollen Sponsors
surfshark einspielen und danach sofort
ungestört fortfahren zu können denn
surfshark BPN ist ein wirklich
empfehlenswertes und sicheres VPN
welches zum Beispiel keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mit lockt natürlich
kein ein worcial private networkurs VPN
eine nicht vor allem gefahrenschützen
die im Netz lauern man muss nach wie vor
Umsicht behalten lassen und wissen was
man tut aber es stellt hierfür ein
Werkzeug mit gleich mehreren Vorteilen
da zum einen erschwert ist in
Kombination mit anderen Vorkehrungen
eure Aktionen messen nachzuverfolgen und
abzuhören mit Hilfe verschiedener
Sicherheitsfeatures könnt ihr so eure
Anonymität im Netz erhöhen zum Beispiel
mit dem integrierten clean Web das alle
Cookies und blockt weiterer Vorteil
eines VPN ist dass ihr so tun könnt als
wir den an einem anderen Ort zirkelt ihr
zum Beispiel auf Websites und
Internetdienste zugreifen die in dem
Land in dem wir gerade seid nicht
verfügbar wären auch daheim oder in
Urlaub damit schlagt ihr Zensur und
diablocking ein Schnäppchen Netflix und
anderes trainingsdienste die ihre
Inhalte nur in den USA Anbieten von
Europa ausnutzen oder deutsches
Internetfernsehen im Ausland gucken mit
surfshark kein Problem aber das ist noch
nicht alles damit nur einem surfshark
Konto könnt ihr wirklich alle eure
Endgeräte in VPN registrieren Handys
Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart TV ich
persönlich nutze surfshark und bin von
der Geschwindigkeit und Performance der
Server immer wieder überrascht vor allem
auch im Vergleich mit der Konkurrenz ihr
solltet es also auch unbedingt mal
ausprobieren wenn ihr VPNs nutzen wollt
so und wenn ihr den Rabattcode
politik.de angeben bekommt ihr von
surfshark auch noch ein Rabatt von 83%
und oben dran die ersten drei Monate
gratis dazu links zu diesem Angebot
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video also nicht viel los besorgt
euch damit gleichzeitig auch uns
finanzielle unter die Arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe eines
paypal-spenden Links den ich euch
ebenfalls in die Beschreibung gepackt
habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung dankbar denn damit hält
ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr und
noch bessere Videos zu liefern so und
nun zurück zu unserer Geschichte
Russlands grausame Invasion der Ukraine
liegt darauf folgenden internationalen
Sanktionen haben die Länder der
Europäischen Union direkt ins Fadenkreuz
Wladimir Putins gebracht denn sie sind
das ideale und die wir später sehen
werden lange auserkorene Ziel eines
großen geostrategischen
wirtschaftskriegs Russlands vor allem in
mitteleuropäischen Ländern wie
Tschechien Österreich Deutschland oder
Polen können Winter durchaus strengt
werden oder ein großer Teil des
wohnungs- und hausbestands weist immer
noch eine eher unzureichende
Wärmedämmung auf und Vladimir Putin weiß
für Dutzende von Millionen Menschen in
solchen Wohnungen Häusern stellt es eine
fast unlösbare Aufgabe da ja eine
lebensbedrohliche Situation einen Winter
ohne Heizung zu verbringen und der
Knackpunkt an der ganzen Geschichte ist
wie man dieser Karte nehmen kann das zu
Bewältigung dieses Problems viele
europäische Länder extrem abhängig
geworden sind von russischem Gas unter
all diesen Ländern gibt es einen Fall
der wegen seines enormen Verbrauchs und
der Bedeutung seiner Wirtschaft für die
gesamte Europäische Union besonders
auffällig ist es handelt sich um keinen
geringen als den wirtschaftlichen Motor
und den mit Abstand größten
Beitragszahler des europäischen Klubs na
wer kann da wohl gemeint sein klar es
kann sich nur um Deutschland handeln
in der ersten Hälfte des Jahres 2022 lag
die Abhängigkeit Deutschlands von
russischen Gas trotz des Ukraine Kriegs
noch immer bei rund 40 Prozent kein
Wunder dass ein kompletter lieferstock
durch Moskau der Albtraum der deutschen
wirtschaftlich als auch gesellschaftlich
man fürchtete das durch explodierende
Gaspreise viel Unternehmen ihre
Produktion einstellen und ja deswegen
dann pleite gehen würden und das
natürlich die Heizung nicht mehr
funktionieren würde wenn der winterkalt
wird
so sieht die Erzeugerpreise also die
Kosten zu den deutschen Unternehmen ihre
Güter erzeugen in juli um 50% in die
Höhe gestellt das ist ein unglaublicher
Anstieg der entweder zu einem massiven
Verfall ihrer Wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu
einer Preisinflation auch für
Verbraucher eine gewaltigen Einbruch der
Kaufkraft und einer Pleitewelle führen
kann aber wie groß diese Gefahr wirklich
ist werden wir am Ende dieses Videos
beleuchten fakt ist das Deutschland auf
extreme Weise von russischem Gas
abhängig geworden war war schon seit
langem Jahren kein großes Geheimnis in
der Tat haben wir schon seit langem und
immer wieder in unseren Videos vor der
ersten Gefahr gewarnt die von der
mangelhaften energiediversifizierung des
europäischen wirtschaftsriesen ausgeht
schließlich hat der Kreml in den
vergangenen 20 Jahren mehrfach unter
Beweis gestellt dass er eben kein
zuverlässiger Energielieferant ist wie
die von ihm bezahlten deutschen
Politiker nicht müde wurden zu behaupten
nur traf es in der Vergangenheit eben
immer andere Länder irgendwas im Osten
warum hätten die Ignoranz
selbstverliebten deutschen dies auch auf
sich beziehen sollen es ist so ähnlich
wie mit dem Krieg in der Ukraine auch
heute sind noch immer in Deutschland der
Meinung er ginge sie nicht die Bohne an
sie könnten das Leid der Menschen dort
einfach ausblenden solange es Ihnen
selbst gut ginge vielleicht sollten sie
noch mal in Erdkunde nachsetzen und sich
auf der Karte ansehen ob ihr Häuschen
nicht auch irgendwo zwischen Wladiwostok
und Lissabon liegt den von dimit wird
formulierten Herrschaftsanspruch des
großes russischen Imperiums aber wir
müssen gar nicht auf solche großspurigen
Postulate zurückgreifen beim Thema Gas
geht es nicht um den einfachen
engstirnigen Michel der seine Stube
billig wann bekommen will es war ein
elitäres Kartell aus Politikern und
Wirtschaftsbossen ihnen Lenkern auf die
sich der Michel so gerne verlässt auf
dass sie durch Weise Entscheidungen
seinen Wohlstand sicherer und niemand
von ihnen wollte auf die paar Unkenrufe
hören wieder auf visualpolitik noch auf
Donald Trump und sogar erweise ist
Germany will becomed Deutschland wird
völlig abhängig sein von der russischen
Energie wenn es nicht sofort den Kurs
ändert hier in der westlichen Hemisphäre
setzen wir uns dafür ein unsere
Unabhängigkeit vor dem Eindringen
expansionistischer ausländischer Mächte
zu schützen aber lasst uns dieses Video
hier für einen Moment anhalten genau
hier wo wir die deutsche Delegation
sehen können die über Trump lacht tja
das ging eben so lange gut bis das Kind
jetzt endgültig in den Brunnen gefallen
ist
und wieder einmal wie nach so vielen
vorherigen Vorteil Fehlentscheidung der
deutschen Eliten die das Land immer
wieder in den Abgrund geführt haben
stellt sich nun die Frage was kann man
daraus lernen wie kam Deutschland
überhaupt in diese Situation warum hat
sich das Land so stark von Lieferungen
aus einem Land die Russland abhängig
gemacht wie konnte es passieren dass
alle entscheidet dieses gigantische
politische Risiko ignorieren konnten und
Medien und Wähler es ihnen durchgehen
lassen was muss ich ändern damit sich
dies nicht wiederholt tja da ist es
wieder dass bei den Deutschen so
beliebte Postulat nie wieder also lasst
uns heute doch etwas Ursachenforschung
betreiben richtig tief bohren da wo es
wirklich weh tut Katharsis ist nun mal
extrem schmerzhaft wenn man große Fehler
begangen hat aber besser ein bewusst
wahrgenommener stechender Schmerz mit
dem die Heilung beginnt als ein
unterdrückter der chronisch wird und nie
verschwindet denn die Wahrheit ist dass
die ganze Angelegenheit schon sehr lange
im Gange ist und dass die dafür
verantwortlichen Strukturen extrem
komplex sind ja es handelt sich um ein
strukturelles Problem eine Krankheit die
den deutschen tief in den Knochen sitzt
die Zahl der Verantwortlichen ist
unglaublich groß und viele von ihnen
sitzen noch immer in ihren warmen
Sesseln manche sogar in noch größeren
als vorher es hilft nicht nur einzelne
Sündenböcke zu opfern und dann weiter zu
machen bisher nicht einmal den
ehemaligen Bundeskanzler Gerhard
Schröder der von Putin einen
millionengehalt erhielt und jetzt in
Deutschland so ein paar Jahren geworden
ist aber wartet ein Moment denn in
diesem Video werden wir nicht nur
feststellen wer die Schuld an
Deutschland noch mal Schwäche trägt
sondern werden auch versuchen zu
verstehen in welcher Situation sich das
Land genau befindet was dich zu Folge
haben kann und was ist angehen muss um
irgendwann einen Ausweg aus der Misere
zu finden also schnallt euch an es geht
sofort los
[Musik]
mein russischer Freund
die Beziehung ist zwischen den Deutschen
und in Russland vor allem in Sachen
Energie sind nicht gerade neu das Modell
der wirtschaftlichen Symbiose zwischen
Deutschland und Russland ist mehrere
hundert Jahre alt mindestens seit dem 19
Jahrhundert profitieren beide
seitenwirtschaftlich voneinander
wirklich unterbrochen wurde diese
Partnerschaft eigentlich nur durch Adolf
Hitler aber nach und nach wurde sie
wieder hergestellt am ersten Februar
1970 unterzeichneten hochrangige
Politiker und Vertreter der Gasindustrie
aus Deutschland oder damaligen
Sowjetunion den Vertrag über den Bau der
ersten Gaspipeline zwischen den
sibirischen Gasfeldern und den
Verbrauchern in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ja das ist richtig nicht
einmal der Eiserne Vorhang die
undurchlässige und eisige Barriere die
den Kalten Krieg beherrschte hinter des
russische Gas daran von den sowjetischen
vorderfeldern in den Westen zu fließen
[Musik]
und es war nicht nur so dass das Gas
zwischen den verfeindeten Ländern zu
fließen begangen sondern das nicht
einmal die größten Spannung des Kalten
Krieges die Versorgung gefährden konnten
und so hat diese Sicherheitsgefühl im
Laufe der Jahrzehnte dazu geführt dass
ich Zuschnitt deutschen und den Russen
nach und nach starken
Vertrauensbeziehungen und
handelsfreundschaften entwickelt haben
ihr ausgangspunkt war die Ostpolitik der
ersten SPD geführten Bundesregierung
nach den Krieg und der Bundeskanzler
beliebt
[Musik]
Wandel durch Handel hieß die Devise die
Theorie war dass der Start
Totalitarismus durch den Austausch
aufgeweicht wird und es dort dadurch
irgendwann zu einer Liberalisierung
kommt die Wahrheit war jedoch eine ganz
andere denn wenn diese Beziehungen so
lange gehalten haben dann vor allem
deshalb weil sie seit fast 50 Jahren für
beide Seiten viele Vorteile gebracht
haben an erster Stelle kam wie immer
Geld danach lange nichts und dann wieder
jede Menge Geld Kohle Zaster das war
lange die Hauptmotivation bei der Seiten
Deutschland zum Beispiel profitierte
jahrzehntelang von den reichlichen und
gegen Gasvorkommen um seine
energiehungrige Schwerindustrie zu
betreiben eine Industrie die sich auf
diese Weise sowohl auf europäischer als
auch globaler Ebene in eine sehr
wettbewerbsfähige Position bringen
konnte ohne in Energiesparmaßnahmen
investieren zu müssen genau das ist der
Grund warum der deutsche Verbrauch von
russischem Gas ständig und immer weiter
gestiegen ist bis 2021
im Gegenzug erhielt die Sowjetunion und
später Russland nicht nur eine riesige
Menge an Devisen sondern Deutschland
behandelte Russland auch als vorrangige
Partner und verkaufte ihn alle Arten von
Industriegütern und Spitzentechnologie
es war eine ganz klare lupenrein
ökonomische Win-Win-Situation für beide
Seiten aber lasst uns zu der Frage
zurückkehren die wir uns vorhin schon
gestellt haben warum hat sich
Westdeutschland entschieden sich
ausgerechnet in die Arbeit
destruiertunion und des Ostblock zu
werfen um seinen Energiebedarf zu decken
nun wie gesagt nutzen deutsche Politiker
und Wirtschaftsbosse damals nur allzu
gerne das Feigenblatt namens Wandel
durch Wandel um ihres skrupellose
profitglied zu verdecken die sehr
ungemütliche Tatsache dass sie damit das
despotische Imperium das eine Atomwaffen
auf sie gerichtet hatte mit dem Wiesen
und Technologie versorgen und ist damit
länger am Leben erhalten in
Sonntagsreden versuchten sie das
Wahlvolk davon zu überzeugen dass die
Förderung des Handels mit dem Ostblock
der beste Weg war die politische
Stabilität in Europa zu verbessern
innerhalb der SPD aber auch unter vielen
anderen linksintellektuellen gibt es bis
heute welche die Ostpolitik des
ehemaligen Bundeskanzlers Willy Brandt
zu ihrer eigenen unverrückbaren
Identität erklärt haben wobei sie Brands
Philosophie dabei auch noch grotesk
missverstehen sie stellen die Lieferung
von schweren Waffen an die Ukraine in
Frage und drängen auf irgendwelche
Verhandlungen mit Putin welche sie
jedoch selbst nicht konkretisieren
können dieses geschichtliche ehrlich
dann basiert auf einer gravierenden
Fehleinschätzung der heutigen Situation
wie auch das historischen Kontextes denn
sie blenden vollkommen aus das
Westdeutschland unterbrand den größten
Verteidigungshaushalt hatte und die
Ostpolitik ein Projekt der Realpolitik
war es handelte sich damals nicht um ein
naives pazifistisches Projekt sondern
beruhte auf Positionen der Stärke nicht
der Abhängigkeit Brand stand fest an der
Seite der Westalliierten seine Rolle
weil die des Guten Bullen und das andere
den bösen konnten aber er war ein Bulle
eine westbulle das vergaß er nie er
zersetzt wieder die Abwehrbereitschaft
der Bundeswehr noch führte er
Deutschland in eine energiepolitische
Abhängigkeit wie es eine nach schön
Angela Merkel tat das Problem ist
nämlich dass der Handel mit Energie
nicht wieder Kauf von Autos
Waschmaschinen oder Turnschuhen ist
Energie ist die Grundlage des
Produktions- und Wirtschaftssystems und
deshalb ist es wichtig eine robuste und
resiliente Energieversorgung zu sichern
auch wenn dies mit höheren Kosten
verbunden ist Resilienz ist nämlich das
Zauberwort sich in diesem vitalen
Bereich abhängig oder gar erpressbar zu
machen ist die Ursünde der Wirtschafts-
und Geopolitik die Idee dass irgendetwas
oder irgendjemand die Versorgung
unterbrechen könnte kamen deutschen
Politikern jedoch irgendwie erst in den
Sinn als es fünf nach zwölf war
eine langfristige Unterbrechung der
Energieversorgung würde dem
Eigeninteresse das verwirrt-union
zuwiderlaufen Bericht der deutschen
Ministerien Ende der 1980er Jahre
wer miteinander Handel treibt schießt
nicht aufeinander Helmut Schmidt
ehemaliger Bundeskanzler der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland zu Jimmy
Carter von der wirtschaftlichen
Abhängigkeit der Bundesrepublik von
Moskau in einem Maße zu sprechen dass
die Außenpolitik beeinflusst Zeug von
Unwissenheit oder Böswilligkeit Helmut
Schmidt im Jahr 1980 und auf diese Weise
entwickelte Deutschland bis zum Jahr
2021 eine starke Abhängigkeit von
Russland in diesem Jahr kamen nicht
weniger als 55% des gesamten
Gasverbrauchs aus Russland die
öffentliche Meinung wurde von den
innerdeutschen Propagandisten dabei
stets in einem bestimmte Richtung
gesteuert je mehr billiges russisches
Gas nach Deutschland kommt desto besser
[Musik]
erinnert ihr euch noch was zum Beispiel
geschah als die inländische deutsche
Gasförderung aufgrund der Erschöpfung
einiger Felder und vor allem des Drucks
von Umweltgruppen die Gasförderung in
Deutschland ganz einzustellen zu sinken
begann drei zwei eins genau die
Deutschen haben die Russen einfach um
noch mehr Gas gebeten
nach dem Fall des Eisernen Vorhangs
wurde zudem noch kräftig die gefährliche
Illusion befeuert es handelt sich bei
Russland plötzlich um ein demokratisches
und friedfertiges Land Bundeskanzler
Schröder nannte seine späteren oder
vielleicht auch schon damaligen Boss
Putin einen Lupen reinen Demokraten alle
Warnzeichen wurden geflissentlich
ignoriert und vom Tisch [ __ ] ob die
brutalen Kriege in Tschetschenien und
Georgien die unzähligen Morde an
Journalisten und Oppositionellen die
Gleichschaltung der Medien und die immer
lauter über sie verbreitete
nationalistische und imperialistische
hass- und kriegspopaganda und nicht
zulässt die Erpressung anderer Länder
durch Einstellung von Gaslieferungen das
alles wurde ausgeblendet denn die
Komplizenschaft mit den Mafiosi die sich
den russischen Staat und seine
Reichtümer unter den Nagel gerissen
hatten war einfach zu lukrativ nicht
einmal nach der Invasion und der
anschließenden Annexion der Creme haben
deutsche Politiker Schritte unternommen
um ihre Energiequellen zu
diversifizieren dabei war die deutsche
Politik umgekehrt aber nie sonderlich
verlegen auch sehr weit entfernte
Ereignis Preis Motivation und
Rechtfertigung für harte und teure
politische Weichenstellungen zu benutzen
um sich noch mehr von Russland abhängig
zu machen Deutschland will alle
Atomreaktoren abschalten auslöser sind
Massenproteste gegen Atomkraft nach der
Atomkatastrophe in Japan aber wen
kümmerte das schon solange deutsche
Politiker wirtschaftliche Erfolg und
billige Energie verkaufen konnten warum
sollte man sich über das was in Russland
und im Osten passiert Gedanken machen
warum Zeit damit verschwenden über Dinge
wie Demokratie irgendwelche kleinen
Länder in Osteuropa oder auch die eigene
Energiesicherheit nachzudenken wenn das
Blut Geld doch so schön in die eigenen
Taschen fließt genau das war die
Mentalität des ehemaligen deutschen
Bundeskanzlers Gerhard Schröder er
führte sein Land das auch damals als der
kranke Mann Europas abgestempelt war
zwischen 1998 und 2005 aus der damaligen
Wirtschaftskrise und berühmte sich nicht
nur Putins enger Freund zu sein und den
häufig zu besuchen sondern er arbeitet
auch ein Projekten die mit der
russischen Regierung verbunden waren und
die er selbst gefördert hatte das war
zum Beispiel bei der Fall eine von
Russland kontrollierten Unternehmen zu
den Bau der ersten unterwasserpipeline
zwischen Russland und Deutschland
verantwortlich war
Putin wickelte Schröder um seinen Finger
eine Geschichte wie aus dem KGB Handbuch
über die Anwerbung inoffizieller
Mitarbeiter er wusste genau was er den
Narzissten Schröder bieten musste
Komplimente mon denen Pomp und natürlich
reichlich Marmore nur kurze Zeit nachdem
Schröder wiederbele ich das Kanzleramt
verlassen musste wurde er Vorsitzender
des AKTIONÄR Ausschusses jeder
Gesellschaft deren Pipeline seine
Regierung zuvor genehmigt hatte
nordstream und als Gegenleistung für
eine großzügiges Gehalt opferte Schröder
dann seinen wohlverdienten Ruhestand
dafür in ganz Deutschland für die
Vorteile russischen Gases zu werden
alles natürlich schön in das höhere
generativ der Völkerverständigung
verpackt natürlich war dies nicht ein
einziges Engagement seit 2017 saß
Schröder auch im Verwaltungsrat des
russischen ölkonzers rasiert der Lohn
dafür dass er diesen Sessel warm hielt
weitere 600 000 $ pro Jahr er hat das
Ansehen und den Einfluss des Kanzleramts
ausgenutzt und sich als Agent für
russische interessenangeboten um sich zu
bereichern Norbert Rott ehemaliger
CDU-Minister aber Schröder bildete nur
die Spitze des Eisbergs und war beileibe
kein Einzelfall viele deutsche Politiker
waren direkt oder indirekt an diesen
riesigen Geschäft beteiligt bis die
Blase Plaste ihre Ausrede war stets das
Russland niemals die Gaslieferung
unterbrechen würde weil es kein
Interesse daran hätte einen so großen
wirtschaftlichen Verlust hinzunehmen es
würde doch auch nicht seine eigenen
Pipeline sprengen oder nun sie haben nie
kapiert oder wollten nicht kapieren das
ist sich bei Gazprom nicht um ein
reguläres Wirtschaftsunternehmen handelt
dessen Ziel die Profitmaximierung wäre
und dass ich entsprechend ökonomisch
rational verhalten würde denn nichts
könnte von der Realität weiter entfernt
sein bei Gastraum rasiert und all den
anderen russischen Rohstoffunternehmen
geht es nur am Rande um Wirtschaft und
Geld verdienen klar die viel Milliarden
werden gerne mitgenommen an die Amigos
verteilt und mit dem Rest
kriegefinanziert und die Bevölkerung
abgespeist in Wahrheit handelt es sich
bei diesen Organisationen jedoch um
nichts anderes als Waffen des Scrabble
Krieg gegen andere Länder ihr Ziel ist
nicht die Gewinnmaximierung sondern die
Durchsetzung der imperialistischen
nationalistischen Agenda der putinisten
an allen Schaltstellen dieser Konzerne
sitzen anstelle erfahrener
Wirtschaftsmanager und Putin Hand
verlassene Geheimdienstleute die rein
gar nichts von Betriebsführung verstehen
dafür aber sehr viel von Politik und
davon die man Machtstrukturen
kontrolliert und zwar sowohl jene in
Russland als auch die in den zu
unterjochenden Ländern und der beste
Beweis dafür dass Putin den Krieg gegen
die Ukraine und auch gegen Europa
inklusive Deutschland schon längere Zeit
plante ist eben die Tatsache dass das
kommt bereits im Sommer 2021 die durch
die Regierung Merkel also übergebenen
deutschen Gasspeicher nicht wie in allen
Jahren üblich auffüllen ließ dieses
vollkommen unübliche Verhalten des
Gasversorgers macht deutlich dass ihr
ganz klar die erpressungsgrundlage für
die Kriegssituation in 2022 gelegt wurde
und waren Putins Erpressungsopfer zu vor
Länder wie Belarus die Ukraine baltische
oder Polen gewesen hat er diesmal ganz
klar Deutschland ins Fadenkreuz einer
Gaswaffe genommen denn so wie für einen
Recep Tiefe Erdogan die Demokratie nicht
mehr als ein Zug ein Mittel war um ein
sein tatsächliches Ziel zu kommen waren
die rohstoffgeschäfte für Putin auch nur
ein Mittel eine Waffe um seine wahre
Agenda verfolgen zu können und so wie
ein Adolf Hitler von der Weltherrschaft
und der Ausrottung der Juden besessen
war ist Putin von der Errichtung eines
großen russischen Imperiums oder
Auslöschung der Ukraine als Land als
Volk als Kultur besessen alles andere
wird diesen Zielen untergeordnet auch
wenn man sich auf dem Weg dorthin alle
erdenklichen rationalen wirkenden Mittel
verwende und Täuschungsmanöver bedient
um andere an der Nase herumzuführen
[Musik]
das erste große Täuschungsmanöver Putins
im internationalen Maßstab war dabei der
psychoco der ihm bereits 2001 im
Deutschen Bundestag gelangt
ich bin trotzdem auf russisch
in einer Rede auf Deutsch wickelt er
damals Politik Medien und die gesamte
deutsche Öffentlichkeit um den Finger in
dem der vorgab das Russland unter ihm
den Weg der Demokratie Stabilität des
Friedens und der Annäherung an den
Freiheitlichen besten fortführen er gar
verstärken werde jetzt ist dann derzeit
ist an der Zeit daran zu denken was zu
tun ist damit das einheitliche und
sichere Europa zum Vorboten einer
einheitlichen und sicheren Welt wird
müssen wir uns zuerst klar machen von
wem wird uns schützen müssen und wie mit
dem Wirtschaftskultur und
verteidigungspotenziale Russlands der
einigen können
nicht bemerken dass die Welt sich nicht
mehr in zwei feindliche Lager teilt die
Welt ist meine Damen und Herren viel
viel komplizierter geworden
wir sprechen von einer Partnerschaft nur
in Wirklichkeit haben wir immer noch
nicht gelernt einander zu vertrauen und
seitdem wiederholten deutsche Politiker
immer wieder das Mantra Putin sei doch
im Grunde seines Herzens ein Demokrat
aber ein Land wie Russland müsste man
eben etwas autoritärer führen oder aber
vor allem nach 2014 er sei trotz allem
doch ein Weiser einsichtiger und
rationaler Herrscher sogar bis heute
wird diese Rede von vielen noch immer
verwirrten als ein Beweis seine
ursprünglichen Gutmütigkeit und der
durch den Westen verpassten Chance einer
Freundschaft mit Russland angesehen und
ich denke dass viele gutgläubige
Menschen in Deutschland die heute selbst
strikte Putin Gegner geworden sind in
ihrem Inneren noch immer dieses Gefühl
mit sich herumtragen es basiert jedoch
auf einem sehr haterhältlich und sehr
sorgsam ausgearbeiteten Druckbild aus
der Propaganda Schmiede der putinischen
extra geb-klicke aber obwohl es sich
einen über Jahrzehnte angelegten und
ausgeklügel daran handelt konnte man ihn
nur dann auf den Leim gehen wenn man
dies wirklich wollte
[Musik]
putisplan ein souveränes Nachbarland die
Ukraine zu unterwerfen ist über 20 Jahre
alt und bei allen bekannt es wird selbst
von Putins Gefolge bestätigt dass er
spätestens seit der Pro westlichen
sogenannten Orangen Revolution im Jahr
2004 sagt Russland müsse die Ukraine
eindämmen notfalls mit Gewalt wohlgo
wenn ihr in Kiew nicht nach unserer
Pfeife tanzt bringen wir euch einfach um
stellt euch mal vor Berlin würde eine
solche Politik zum Beispiel gegenüber
Österreich fahren und die deutschen
Politiker konnten natürlich sehen dass
die russische Politik in eine ganz
andere Richtung gehen als sie sich in
ihren Illusionen vorgestellt hatten nach
dem Maidan im Jahr 2014 nach ihren
endlosen etwa 20 Telefonaten mit Putin
sagte Angela Merkel dass der Mann in
einer völlig anderen Welt lebe ihre
Schlussfolgerung daraus war jedoch dass
man weiterhin Brücken bauen und
Geschäfte machen ja diese und die eigene
Abhängigkeit von diesem Mann in einer
anderen Welt sogar ausgeweitet werden
soll Merkel immer diese Abhängigkeit auf
gedeiht und Verderb als eine Investition
in die Aufrechterhaltung einer gewissen
Normalität es sollte ein
freundschaftlicher Schritt gegenüber
Russland sein um zu zeigen dass
Deutschland keine Bedrohung darstellt
[Musik]
aber das war noch nicht alles zu allem
Überfluss entschloss sich Merkel noch zu
weiteren fatalen Schritten mit denen sie
Deutschlands Kehle gegenüber dem wilden
russischen Bären vollkommen entblößt es
handelte sich um Schritte epochalen
Ausmaßes Schritte die nur schwer
rückgängig gemacht oder kompensiert
werden können Merkel entwaffnete quasi
die Bundeswehr beschloss den Ausstieg
aus der Kernkraft und überließ zu allen
Überfluss auch noch den Gasspeicher der
russischen Gazprom und zwar auch nachdem
der kremme seit 2014 unverblümt
verkünden lässt dass eine Angriffe auf
die Ukraine nichts anderes sein als ein
Krieg mit dem Westen
für gut informierte dürfte aber dies
auch schon lange vorher keine große
Überraschung gewesen sein schließlich
dürfte den westlichen Geheimdiensten und
damit auch der deutschen Regierung
bereits im Zeitpunkt des bravoösen
Auftritts im Bundestag 2001 bekannt
gewesen sein wer Wladimir Putin wirklich
ist dass er 1999 als Premierminister
seine fsb-kumpels eines Serie von
Terroranschlägen unter falscher Flagge
inszenieren ließ bei den 367 unschuldige
Menschen ums Leben kamen damit schuf er
die Rechtfertigung den 1996 beendeten
Tschetschenienkrieg wieder fortzusetzen
crosny dem Erdboden gleich zu machen und
sich als starken Mann und mache in Szene
zu setzen der besten least Putin seine
Gräueltaten durchgehen da er mit ihrer
Hilfe bei den Präsidentschaftswahl im
März 2000 die Kommunisten schlagen
konnte
wie so oft drückte man im Westen alle
Augen zu um das noch größere Übel zu
verhindern und zwar auch als er
anschließend zahlreiche russische
Journalisten und Politiker die diese
Vorgänge untersuchen wollten ermorden
ließ so wie viele andere seine Kritiker
und Oppositionellen in den folgenden
Jahren wir haben ein Video darüber
gemacht
[Musik]
es macht jedoch einen großen Unterschied
ob man einen skrupellosen schlechter nur
als Schachfigur in seinem geopolitischen
Spiel nutzt oder ob man diesen zu seinem
Freund oder ob man sich sogar von ihnen
abhängig macht und während andere
Staaten an dieser Stelle einen für sie
sichere Ball lose gefunden haben hinten
ist die deutschen Politiker und
Wirtschaftsführer für klüger ihre
geostrategische Urteilskraft direkt an
den Kreml zu delegieren diese kolossale
viel Einschätzung recht sich nun
gewaltig mitgefangen mitgehangen denn
wer sich trotz aller Alarmzeichen und
Warnungen die falschen Freunde aussucht
muss irgendwann auch für deren Fehler
mit bezahlen genau an diesem Punkt steht
Deutschland heute und mit ihm halb
Europa vor diesem Hintergrund stellt
sich die Frage wie tief das Problem in
Deutschland eigentlich reicht was
eigentlich die Wurzel des ganzen Übels
ist und was man tun sollte und diese
Wurzeln langfristig und nachhaltig
auszurotten genau das sehen wir uns
jetzt an
[Musik]
das Spiel das verloren war bevor es
begonnen hatte
was ihr in dieser Grafik seht ist die
Art und Weise wie der Gasverbrauch in
Deutschland im vergangenen Jahr verteilt
war wie ihr seht war der größte deutsche
Gasverbraucher die Industrie
insbesondere die Schwerindustrie die
sehr energieintensiv ist insgesamt
verschlagen sich fast 40% des
Gesamtverbrauchs dann gibt es noch die
Haushalte die für etwas mehr als 30% des
Gasverbrauchs verantwortlich waren
hauptsächlich für Heizung Warmwasser und
kochen und zwischen 9 und 15% des
gesamten Gasverbrauchs werden für die
Stromerzeugung verwendet da Gas also
sehr wichtig ist damit die deutsche
Industrie nicht abgewürgt wird haben
deutsche Politiker noch bevor Putin die
Gaslieferungen nach Deutschland über den
Nordseebad komplett gestoppt hat die
Europäische Kommission dazu gezwungen
einen Plan zu Reduzierung des
Gasverbrauchs in ganz Europa
durchzusetzen und da die deutsche
Industrie der Motor der gesamten
europäischen Wirtschaft ist hat Europa
keine andere Chance als auf diese
Forderung einzugehen auch all jene
Staaten die daran so gut wie keinen
Anteil hatten aber wartet mal der nicht
alles ist die Schuld Russlands
Deutschlands selbst beim unvermeidlicher
Komplize der diese Situation herbeige
hat und wir reden hier nicht über die
Gier nach billigem Gas aus Russland
[Musik]
mit der sogenannten Energiewende hat
Deutschland 14 seine 17 Atomreaktoren
abgeschaltet die Idee dahinter war sie
durch saubere Energien zu ersetzen das
Problem dabei ist dass die
gebräuchlichsten erneuerbaren Energien
Wind uns oder Allergie nicht in der Lage
sind regelmäßig Strom zu liefern so dass
eine dritte Energiequelle als Backup
benötigt wird und die deutsche Politik
hat dafür gesorgt dass diese dritte
Energiequelle Gaskraftwerke sind aber
das ist noch nicht alles für Deutschland
war es auch viel schwieriger russisches
Gas zu ersetzen als für andere
europäische Länder warum nun weil es
keine Alternative Infrastruktur
geschaffen hat als russisches Gas in
rauen Mengen durch Pipelines ins
landströmte entschied sich Deutschland
gegen den Bau von wieder
verdampfungsanlagen um Flüssiggas
importieren zu können Flüssiggas kurz
LNG kann an Bord großer Tanker
transportiert werden was bedeutet das
ist bei der Ankunft im Hafen
registifizierungsanlagen benötigt um es
sicher in den gasförmigen Zustand
zurückzuversetzen mit anderen Worten wir
reden nicht nur davon dass die Deutschen
nicht nach alternativen Quellen gesucht
und sich keine Gedanken über ihre
Abhängigkeit von russischen Gas gemacht
haben sondern sie haben nicht einmal
eine passive Infrastruktur für den Fall
der Fälle aufgebaut wie es andere Länder
getan haben vor etwa 10 Jahren
investierte das kleine Litauen zum
Beispiel in ein schwimmendes Terminal
zur Lagerung und wieder Verdampfung von
Flüssiggas es heißt treffend
independence und liegt im Hafen von
Kleid Peter im Anker dank dieser Anlage
war Litauen das erste europäische Land
es kein Gas mehr aus Russland bezogen
obwohl es vorher vollkommen abhängig war
an dieser Stelle müssen wir doch noch
mit einem weiteren Mythos aufräumen den
ich in den vergangenen Minuten sogar
selbst in den Mund genommen habe mit dem
Märchen des achso belegenen russischen
Erdgases und der daraus erwachsenen
unersetzbaren Vorteile für die deutsche
Industrie denn auch wenn der Mangel an
Gas Einzelunternehmen und Branchen hart
treffen mag lag der Gesamtwert des
deutschen Gasverbrauchs unter 2% des BIP
da waren selbst die Ausfälle aufgrund
der corona-lockdowns größer außerdem
geht die deutsche Wirtschaft bereits
sehr effizient mit dem Gas um
Deutschland verbraucht wesentlich
weniger Gas pro bip-einheit als andere
große Länder mit Ausnahme Frankreich
dass er konsequent auf Kernkraft setzt
diese Indikatoren zeigen die deutsche
Wirtschaft von der intensiven
Energienutzung weniger abhängig ist als
die meisten anderen und vor allem
widerlegen die Daten der letzten Jahre
das landläufig verbreitete Argumente das
Russland seine Energie besonders billig
an Deutschland verkauft habe in den
letzten zehn Jahren hat die deutsche
Industrie etwa 10% mehr für Erdgas
bezahlt als ihre Konkurrenz in den
anderen großen EU-Ländern dank der
Versorgung aus der Nordsee bezahlten
britische Industrieunternehmen sogar
noch weniger als ihre Konkurrenz auf dem
Kontinent implizit lässt das die
Vermutung aufkommen dass sich Russland
fast ohne Kosten eine nicht
wirtschaftlichen das heißt politischen
Vorteil verschaffen konnte und zwar
durch die deutsche Abhängigkeit von
seinen Gaslieferungen im Umkehrschluss
bedeutet dies dass Deutschland einen
Verlust an Energieunabhängigkeit
hinnehmen musste ohne einen spürbaren
wirtschaftlichen Vorteil zu erlangen nun
ja wie dem auch sei tatsache ist dass
sich die Deutschen mittlerweile zwar
verspätet aber dafür mächtig und im
Schweinsgalopp ins Zeug legen um das
gesamte Szenario zu drehen die Speicher
wurden nach dem Prinzip whatever it
takes bis zum Anschlag gefüllt
mittlerweile auf über 97,5 % die
Laufzeiten von Kohle und Atomkraftwerken
wurden verlängert und es wurden
umfassende finanzhilden zu Entlastung
der Bürger beschlossen jeweils trotzdem
alle vorsorglich Police kaufen und
kälter Duschen auch die deutsche
Industrie zeigt sich flexibler als
gedacht innovative Technik und Maßnahmen
zur Einsparung von Prozesswärme sprießen
die Pilze aus dem Boden aber es kommt
auch dazu dass energieintensive
Produktionsanlagen vorerst stillgelegt
werden mussten dass sie nicht mehr
konkurrenzfähig arbeiten können wie zum
Beispiel beim Stahlhersteller Metall in
Hamburg
[Musik]
und das alles zeigt in Kombination mit
dem warmen Wetter tja Putin hast diesen
Trick eine enorme Wirkung in den Wochen
vor der Aufnahme dieses Videos lag der
Gasverbrauch der deutschen Industrie 25%
unter dem Schnitt hervorjahren und der
der Haushalt und Gewerbekunden gab um
satte 41 Prozent darunter der day Heft
futuregaspreis in Deutschland ist so
stark eingebrochen dass er nur noch ein
Drittel des vorkriegsniveaus beträgt die
LNG Tanker stauen sich vor den
europäischen Terminals weil Deutschland
plötzlich viel weniger Gas braucht als
die Händler angenommen hatten und die
Grünen und ihre Spitzenpolitiker Werbung
und Habeck fühlen sich nun in allen
bestätigt schließlich waren sie
ideologisch schon immer klare Vertreter
der Politik des Rückzugs aus Russland
diese abkupplung schreitet nun in
rasanten Tempo voran die deutsche
Wirtschaft zieht sich mit wenigen
Ausnahmen aus Russland zurück die
Jahrhunderte alte Symbiose geht
blitzartig zu Ende
[Musik]
die Grünen zeichnen dabei eine für sie
eindeutige Zukunft eine Großteil der
Rohstoffe die Russland früher im Rahmen
dieses Geschäftsmodells nach Deutschland
geliefert hat ist Ihrer Meinung nach im
Kontext der dekarbonisierung sowieso
nicht mehr relevant ja aber die Zukunft
ist genauso wenig eindeutig wie die
Rolle der Grünen in der Vergangenheit
schließlich waren sie es die durch die
jahrzehntelange Stigmatisierung der
ihrer Meinung nach bösen Energieträger
erst den wichtigsten Grundstein für die
krasse Abhängigkeit von Putins
Energielieferungen gelegt haben sie
waren es die ganze Zeit das Märchen von
den omnipotenten ökoallergien erzielten
die angeblich bereitstünden sobald Kohle
und Naturstrom nicht mehr das Netz
verstopfen sie haben die Illusion an
eine schnelle wundersame und
schmerzfreie Energiewende in den Köpfen
der Bevölkerung erst verankert die
Opportunisten Merkel sprang dann nur auf
diesen Zug auf um den Grünen Wähler
abzusagen wir haben darüber ein Video
gedreht
[Musik]
Hand in Hang führten dann grünen CDU CSU
und SPD in der großen Koalition eine
Bevölkerung an der Nase herum die den
kollektiven ihre Glauben an die
verzichtbarkeit fossile Energieträger
wie auch der Kernkraft erlag das
traurige Ergebnis war eine Mogelpackung
aus russischen Gas in der der sich auch
2021 noch ein Primärenergiebedarf
verbaut der Zukunft 85% durch fossile
Energieträger gedeckt wurde Windräder
trugen nur kümmerliche 3,6% breiten
Solaranlagen noch weniger auch die
sagenumwobenen Energiespeicher blieben
ein leeres Versprechen da technisch kaum
zu realisieren Deutschland verbraucht
pro Tag im Schnitt 1,4 Terawattstunden
Strom verfügt jedoch auch nach vielen
Jahren forcierten Ausbaus nur über
Speicherkapazitäten von
0,04 Terawattstunden das heißt das Land
könnte selbst bei voller Ladung und
Entladung aller Energiespeicher gerade
mal in Mittel 40 Minuten überbrücken
wenn die Sonne nicht scheint und der
Wind nicht weht
[Musik]
klar der Ausbau der Erneuerbaren ist
wichtig denn mit seinem brutal
Imperialismus hat Putin den Prozess der
dekarbonisierung nochmals beschleunigt
die Internationale Energieagentur
prognostiziertes wegen dass die
Nachfrage nach fossilen Energieträgern
weltweit bereits ab Mitte dieses
Jahrzehnts nicht mehr weiter wachsen
wird je nach Öl immerhin ab Mitte der
2030er Jahre aber bis dahin wird sie
eben wachsen und auch danach wieder
schlagartig verschwinden noch
realistisch komplett ersetzt werden
können das Hirngespinst das regenerative
Energien in den nächsten Jahren
nennenswerte Beiträge zur Lösung der
Energiekrise liefern da das politische
Handeln daher nicht länger leiten und
schon gar nicht zur Abhängigkeit von
irgendeinem Schurken stattfinden ein
langfristiger ausgewogener nachhaltiger
und vor allem sicherer Übergang ist
notwendig eine Politik der Städten und
ruhigen Hand nicht der ruckartigen
wenden irgendwann kann auch der
gasimport aus Russland wieder
aufgenommen werden nur eben auf einem
vollkommen risikolosen Niveau
[Musik]
denn Fakt ist selbst wenn früher oder
später ein internationales Abkommen zur
beiligung des Krieges erreicht werden
sollte wird es sicherlich kein Abkommen
sein dass auf einem Vertrauensvorschuss
basiert es muss Verhandlungen geben ja
aber ein Dialog auf Augenhöhe mit
Russland ist vorbei die deutsche Seite
spricht manchmal von Dialog aber im
Grunde meint sie damit Verhandlungen der
sich schon über viele Generationen
erstreckende Dialog Deutschlands mit
Russland ist eine der Brücken die Putin
nun endgültig gesprengt hat tatsächlich
befindet sich Deutschland aber erst am
Anfang eines grundsätzlichen
Paradigmenwechsels in seiner Geopolitik
da die Änderung der sogenannten
part-dependency also die kontinuierliche
Linie politischen Denkens eine sehr
schwerfällige Prozess ist der auch stark
personell geprägt ist es dauert sehr
lange eine solche strategische Kultur zu
verändern es braucht einen
Generationswechsel der bei den Grünen
schon stattgefunden hat aber noch nicht
bei der SPD die CDU ist sowieso ein
Thema für sich sie wird noch so einige
Zeit brauchen um sich vom märkischen
Kahlschlag zu erholen und zwar nicht nur
vom personellen sondern auch von dem in
den Gehirnen der kastrierten
konservativen wenn für dieses Land noch
irgendwas zustande bringen wollen müssen
Sie sich einfach alle mal von der
Kuschel Droge lösen die Merkel Ihnen
über viele Jahre lang eingeflößt hat und
wieder lernen ordentlich anzuecken für
die Werte der eigenen Wählerschaft
einzustehen ohne diese verschämt zu
verklausulieren oder wie es einer
unserer Zuschauer treffend in den
Kommentaren formuliert hat Merkel war im
Grunde nur die wohlfühlmotive all
diejenigen die von der schlichtteil und
Unscheinbarkeit dieser Frau so
begeistert waren wie von ihrer
heimischen Raufasertapete und Demokratie
sollte nie wie eine Raufasertapete sein
sie lebt vom Wettbewerb politische
Position nicht von behauptete
Alternativlosigkeit und der anbieterung
an hysterische Launen bestimmter
Bevölkerungsgruppen denn genau daraus
entspringen dann fatale
Fehlentscheidungen wie zum Beispiel
merkt das atomausstiegskehrtwende alle
wissen mittlerweile dass diese
Entscheidung nicht technischer sondern
rein politisch opportunistischer Natur
war nun ja alle bis auf die Grünen es
wäre Selbstmord für die Grünen zu sagen
dass wir uns bei der Atomkraft geehrt
haben also sind sie ge mit dem alten
Schlachtplan weiterzumachen Thomas einen
Deutschland ansässiger energieanalyst
und Atomphysiker diese störrische und
irrationale Haltung konnten die Grünen
unter Merkel zur Staatspolitik machen
und das obwohl sie überhaupt nicht in
der Regierung saßen ein Husarenstück ein
weiteres Beispiel für die krude wasch
mich aber macht mich nicht nass
Philosophie der Grünen ist ihre nach wie
vor starre Position gegenüber der
Gewinnung heimischen schiefergases durch
Fracking es interessiert sie einfach
nicht dass die Technik mittlerweile
ausgereift ist und Geologen genau
bestimmen können wo sie gefahrlos und
umweltverträglich eingesetzt werden kann
und das Trinkwasser zu gefährden so
vernünftig und konsequent die Grünen in
der Außenpolitik gegenüber Putin
auftreten so borniert sind Sie wenn es
um die heiligen Kühe ihre Ideologie geht
auch wenn es sich bei diesem Kühen schon
längst um tote Pferde handelt sie werden
bis zum geht nicht mehr geritten doch
diese haltungspolitik zeigt jetzt erste
Risse und aus diesen Rissen kommen die
Lichtstrahlen der Vernunft die Hoffnung
auf eine gesunde Balance in der Außen-
und geopolit in Deutschland das Kuriosa
der Sache für diese Risse ist
ausgerechnet der von uns so oft
gescholtene Kanzler Scholz
verantwortlich
Machtwort im akw-streit Scholz schlägt
sich auf die Seite der Vernunft der
Bundeskanzler hat die Sache entschieden
die drei letzten deutschen
Atomkraftwerke werden bis ins Frühjahr
2023 Strom liefern
natürlich durfte die ganze Sache schon
im Vorfeld mit den Grünen
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck abgesprochen
worden sein so konnte dieser sein
Gesicht gegenüber der Grünen Parteibasis
waren und Scholz bekam eine Grundlage um
das Image eines starken Machers
aufzubauen etwas was auch dringend
benötigt alles war also ein hübsches
Theater damit jeder in der Koalition vor
den eigenen Leuten besser dastehen kann
in der gleichen Woche traf Scholz auch
die Entscheidung zum eingangs erwähnten
Einstieg der chinesischen Reederei kosko
beim tomburger Hafen der genehmigte eine
Minderheitsbeteiligung von
24,9%. aber wie genau ist dies nun
einzuordnen hat der grüne Anton
Hofreiter recht dass dies ein Fehler des
Kanzlers war vergleichbar mit der
Entscheidung seine Vorgängerin Merkel
für nostry 2 nein ganz und gar nicht was
wir hier erleben ist womöglich die
Metamorphose des scholl-formaten zu
einem weisen Realpolitiker der in der
Lage ist eine gesunde Balance in der
Sache zu finden und durchzusetzen das
aus Scholz einen Politiker des Formats
Brand oder Schmidt wird ist allein schon
aufgrund seiner integritätsprobleme aus
der Zeit eher unwahrscheinlich aber
genauso sollte ausgewogene und
differenzierte Außenpolitik Aussehen es
geht nun mal darum die Vorteile
mitzunehmen die Nachteile und Risiken
aber strikt zu begrenzen das Gute ist
Körbchen das Schlechte ins Köpfchen mit
der streckenlimitierung der chinesischen
Beteiligung in Gefahr eines
unbootmäßigen Abhängigkeitsverhältnisses
gebannt die eigenen Interessen jedoch
gewahrt die Bindung eines nach wie vor
für den strauchelnden deutschen Export
wichtigen Handelspartners Deutschland
ist nun mal ein Land dessen Wohlstand in
erster Linie auf dem Handel basiert
vollkommen Autarkie müsste es sich durch
immensen Wohlstandsverlust erkaufen das
Zauberwort heißt daher Wirtschafts- und
energiepolitische Resilienz die goldene
Mittel zwischen den beiden Extremen
Abhängigkeit oder Autarkie genau so
sieht geopolitische Kompetenz aus er
sollte nie um alles oder nichts gehen
sondern immer um das richtige Maß bei
dem niemand übervorteilt oder in eine
riskante Abhängigkeit gebracht wird in
diesem Kontext sollte er die deutsche
Automobil- und Maschinenbauindustrie
ihre internationale Strategie auf den
Prüfstand stellen aber das das ist schon
wieder ein Thema von ganz anderes Video
vergesst also bitte nicht das Abo
unbedingt mit Glöckchen um es auf gar
keinen Fall zu verpassen und sobald ihr
das erledigt habt würde mich noch eure
Meinung zu diesem Thema interessieren
glaubt ihr das ist Deutschland noch
schaffen wird ein geopolitisch
kompetenter Player zu werden haben die
Deutschen ein für alle mal gelernt wie
wichtig es ist Energiesicherheit zu
gewährleisten und werden sie daraus auch
langfristig die richtigen Konsequenzen
ziehen wie immer sind auf eure
angerichte Diskussion schon sehr
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat dir vielleicht auch
etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja gebt
uns bitte ein Like das mit euren
Freunden vergessliches aber mit Löchern
um keines unserer Videos mehr zu
verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
uns hält dieses Projekt weiterzuführen
den PayPal Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video mach's
gut und bis bald
[Musik]